today's draft all-time great plays
coming from a team that ultimately lost
the game shireen you've got a trivia
question for me
i do and i saw the question and i have
just seen the answer and i actually got
it right so the pressure's on you not to
be jan brady on this which running back
mike pulls the record for the most
rushing cindy brady sorry which running
back holds the record for the most
rushing yards in a super bowl loss hint
the opposing defensive coordinator was
not mad about it
you know i i probably would have had a
hard time without the hint but that was
the whole game plan for super bowl 25
bill belichick had to get the giants
defense to buy into the idea that if we
let thurman thomas have 100 rushing
yards we'll win the game they thought he
was crazy they finally bought in it
worked the giants were able to slow down
the passing attack of the bills by
letting thurman thomas run so thurman
thomas final answer
and how many yards did he have mike
they tried it again in super bowl 36 but
mike martz wouldn't take the bait he
continued to try to throw even though
the patriots had dropped like eight guys
into coverage on every play all right
this is one of those days where there
really isn't
a clear cut
i've i've got to take this one
um i'm going to go with hmm boy you
think i'd be prepared for this i'm i'm
going to go with the catch that was made
by jermaine curse in super bowl 49
because that was the moment it felt like
the david tyree catch all over again the
holy crap he's laying on the ground the
ball is bouncing around he did what he
hate that he has the catch
and uh that just set up the dramatic
finish with the interception from
malcolm butler but that was the one
huge to me momentum swing
hey the seahawks are actually going to
do it they're going to repeat as
champions they're going to win this game
and they failed to punch it in uh and
that play i think gets forgotten because
the malcolm butler play was far more
memorable but that to me was the moment
where i thought wow the seahawks are
going to win
and malcolm butler actually tipped that
pass and it was still caught by jermaine
curse and jermaine curse has since said
that he thinks it was the greatest catch
in super bowl history and would be
remembered for that
if the seahawks had held on and won the
game and they probably would have they
were at the five yard line at that point
you remember marshawn lynch gained four
yards on first down and then we all know
what happened with 26 seconds left this
seahawks unfortunately decided to throw
the ball and malcolm butler stepped in
and saved the day so i agree i i think
that was the number one choice mike and
everybody forgets about that play
all right uh what is your number one
choice
you know what i think i'm going to go
with poor leon
because we all remember the super bowl
the cowboys could have set the record
for the most points
in a super bowl win and what happens
leon let's running and he decides to
celebrate and mr bibi comes in and takes
the ball away from him and perhaps one
of the greatest plays in super bowl
history that definitely will be
forgotten because the game was already
over it was a route it would have been
an even bigger route but what a great
play it was uh despite the fact that the
buffalo bills got killed in that game
yeah that was the ultimate hustle play
from don beebe and uh
and it's it's because the game was
otherwise a blowout
that's the one play that still resonates
to this very day and there it is frank
reichen at quarterback for the bills
ball comes out
there goes leon let and then and you can
already see what's coming the ball's
there in that left hand and then he
decides as he gets close to the end zone
he's going to hold it down low and bibi
knocks it out um next one for me super
bowl 43
the moment where i said holy crap the
cardinals are gonna beat the steelers
and be a nine and seven team that wins
the super bowl larry fitzgerald catching
the slant pass and then shot out of a
cannon down the middle of the field at
raymond james stadium
um i i
i
again just like with julio jones just
like with your main curse
that's it it's over that's it that's the
moment and uh unfortunately for the
cardinals for later fitzgerald it wasn't
and centennial san antonio home saved
the day obviously for the steelers that
game made an even bigger play mike and
that's
you know these plays get forgotten
because there's a bigger play after that
play and that's what happened
in that super bowl i'm going to go with
one i'm going to change the tone here
one that's not in the super bowl and
that's odell beckham's great one-handed
catch against brandon carr i was there
in the stadium and it's one of those
where you go
did he just do what i think he just did
and it was on the far side of the field
so you couldn't tell for sure but odell
beckham absolutely caught that ball and
by the way he was interfered with by
brandon carr great story off of that
though a few years later brandon carr
was going to a charity event and i was
there and this kid asked if he could
take a picture with brandon carr and
brandon carr says yeah absolutely it
takes a picture right before the
picture's taken the kid goes like this
like he's odell beckham over the top of
brandon carr so brandon car just kind of
rolled his eyes and and went on but poor
brandon cars to be remembered for that
play forever but guess what the cowboys
won that game dez bryant out dueled
odell beckham caught a second touchdown
pass with a minute and one left cowboys
win the game
you know i had forgotten that the
cowboys even won that game um
all you remember from that night is the
otto beckham jr catch i'm gonna go back
to the first super bowl that i ever
watched a long long time ago there's
that catch oh you're getting pulled down
and what it just that was
that's still i get goosebumps seeing
that now what a catch and if only
beckham can get back to that form with
the browns this year maybe he'll get to
make a catch like that in the super bowl
super bowl
seven
and that was a flag not in orange thanks
pete it was an orange yeah it was an
orange when it should have been a flag
uh
really um next thing you know they're
gonna play the damn play again uh the
the um the super bowl seven
and
the dolphins
undefeated season
14 nothing would have been a shutout
would have been the only shutout in
super bowl history but for
mike bass and this really wasn't a
spectacular play but it is memorable it
was a touchdown for washington
because guerrero your premium after the
bad snap on the field goal attempt the
ball's popping around in the air and
then he tries to throw a pass
looking like tim tebow i'm sorry that
was gratuitous that was unnecessary and
the ball pops up in the air mike bass
grabs it and runs it in for a touchdown
hell of a play losing effort because
washington otherwise had zero points on
the day
that was a great play and i'm gonna
finish with the super bowl too mike i'm
gonna go to super bowl 34. everybody
remembers the last play of the game
right
when mike jones tackled kevin dyson at
the goal line but the play before that
was really the one that set them up to
have a chance to win the game steve
mcnair made just a brilliant scramble i
mean he should have been sacked four or
five six times and somehow manages to
get out of it found kevin dyson and got
him down there where they had a chance
from the 10-yard line to win the game a
16-yard game had a chance to win the
game and of course they came up a half
yard short or we'd still be talking
about that play that got him down to the
goal line uh that got him a super bowl
victory but it didn't happen because of
mike jones
all right a couple other ones real quick
that i got to mention that the aaron
rodgers hail mary's multiple against the
cardinals in a game that arizona won in
overtime in the playoffs the devin
hester opening kickoff touchdown for the
bears in super bowl 41 when tony dundee
decided we're not going to run scared
we're going to kick it to him and i
can't believe he didn't take this one
hollywood henderson ripping the ball
away from terry bradshaw and running it
in for a touchdown back in super bowl
13.
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports